[موسيقى]
هذا هو إصدار أحلام الهواء الواضح
الذي اقتربنا منه أخيرًا مما
كنت أتمنى أن تكون عليه سيارة المستقبل ،
إلا أنه ربما يكون أرخص قليلاً ،
هذه النسخة المتطورة التي
قدناها ستعيدك إلى الوراء  170 ألف
دولار ولكن قبل أن تتحقق من حسابك المصرفي
، تم بيع
هذه السيارة بحوالي 500 ميل من المدى
وقوة 933 حصانًا والتي لا يحتاجها أحد
بخلاف حقوق المفاخرة في سيارة تعمل
بالغاز بهذه القوة الحصانية مثل بوجاتي ،
يمكنك سماع المحرك يعمل مثل  من
الصعب الحصول على هذه القوة
في سيارة كهربائية ، يبدو الأمر وكأنه
لا شيء على الإطلاق ،
سأكون صادقًا ، لم أحب هذه المجموعة
من الكروم على الجانب الأمامي عندما
رأيت السيارة لأول مرة تذكرني بشفرة حلاقة
تنزل في الشارع
لكنها نمت علي
وأحب اللمسة الصغيرة للرجعية على الشارات.
جعبتي الوحيدة  تبدو
مقابض الأبواب الموجودة داخل
آلية الزناد البلاستيكية رخيصة بشكل مثير للصدمة
من الخارج ، وعليك أن تدير
يدك لفتح مقابض الأبواب المنبثقة
من الجانب السفلي مقابل
الاستيلاء بشكل أكثر راحة من الجزء العلوي ،
لكنك تعلم أن هذا هو  سيارة باهظة الثمن
[موسيقى]
الآن فاز الهواء الصافي بالفعل بأفضل
سيارة في الاتجاه العام ، مما يمثل المرة الأولى
التي تفوز فيها أي شركة على الإطلاق بجائزة أفضل
سيارة في هذا العام من خلال سيارتها الأولى
في العقد التي كانت في مرحلة التطوير.
اختراقات كانت تسلا
هي البطل من حيث كفاءة الطاقة ،
لكن الهواء الصافي يتفوق على
كفاءة أقرب منافس تسلا ، فالنموذج
s هناك شيء واحد لا تزال تسلا لا تملكه
بالتأكيد
وهذه الجودة لديهم الكثير من
مشاكل الموثوقية وهذا
هو  نقطة ضعف أعتقد أنها يمكن أن
تستفيد منها بوضوح
إذا كان بإمكانهم بناء هذه السيارات
وبناءها جيدًا ،
فستبدأ في الحصول على الكثير من
عشاق
تسلا ربما  rting لتغيير رأيهم